[Music]
they made it their business to mind your
business there said California wants to
ban unlicensed golf instructors from
giving lessons on city owned courses and
dozens of school districts across the
nation have jumped aboard the chocolate
milk bandwagon such policies may
decrease sugar consumption at Cornell
University researchers caution against
bans because the ancient chocolate milk
out of cafeterias means the kiddos drink
less milk and consume less protein in
calcium forget about unintended
consequences what's most important is
showing people you care about kids
health but this time we zero in on Sandy
Springs Georgia were in ordinance bans
sex toys and less customers have a
prescription or a scientific reason for
buying one this woman who has multiple
sclerosis says she wants the government
to get out of her private life
Melissa Davenport says her condition
makes it very difficult to enjoy sex and
she credits sex toys were saving her
marriage of 24 years she says no doctor
would write her a prescription for a sex
toy and she's filed a lawsuit against
the city
this ordinance basically says that the
government can stick its nose into your
bedroom the state of Alabama is one of
the few other places that ban sex toys
people really do need devices like this
because they need it for health reasons
and afford to end to have a healthy
intimate life with their spouse photo on
Twitter submit your nanny nominees and
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies my debut on this